yeah I mean I just was not having fun I
dunno the pressure was way too much for
what it was the whole point of all of
this is to be fun and on transformers
I'd the last day I got up at like 6:00
a.m. went into the steam room weird in
like Trump Tower in Chicago weird and I
went down in the steam room and I just
sat there for like an hour and I kept
this viel I kept saying myself don't
quit it's the last day don't have to
quit you don't have to make a point you
don't have to blow up at him you don't
have to yell at him just don't quit you
don't need to
well berg at one point when we were in a
field eternam he's like you would quit
if you could but he goes you would quit
if you knew it wouldn't [ __ ] up your
whole [ __ ] in Hollywood you would
totally quit and I was like yeah I would
I really would and then he goes but but
it's when strange is so at the sushi
place I said to him I said you know what
you know I want to ask some questions
I'm like so what how do you do the work
ethic you see this really strong work
ethic and I have similar work I think so
as well work but have you figured out
like how do you do the girl thing how do
you how do you how do you acclimate a
woman into that life and he just kind of
was like I don't know I haven't really
figured that out yet but yeah it's
really difficult and then I was kind of
like what and you know I asked him like
what kind of drives the work ethic what
is it he's like you know I just think
yeah you just want to make these things
that are great and people like them and
so you want to make them even better and
it just takes a lot of work so I just I
keep gave you know you just make it
better make it better make it better
make it better
nice end and what about terrible reviews
like you get such the critics attack you
this is people don't ask these people
yeah yeah yeah actually you're quite
interested in he said we you know Peter
Travers gave me a bad review and I just
sent him the scathing letter and it was
really it was kind of mistake and so I
sent him some letters afterwards but he
just I don't think he'll ever I asked
him to lunch even I really did I mean
this is all Michael Bay being like sweet
and vulnerable and I was like yeah they
why wouldn't you reach out and maybe it
would be nice if Peter Travers would sit
down and kind of go tell me about your
process that's if you're this huge film
critic why wouldn't you want to have
dinner with the but instead Peter
Travers is like I don't do this popcorn
movies trash
yeah so kind of to me made me look at
Peter Travers like and Michael Bay like
Wow
and then I said why do you yell at
people so much you're always yelling at
people and you tell them they're doing
this wrong I saw you know this is like
dg8 insisted and he was like this is why
he'll never be a director because I
asked you for just a list of the stunts
and you come back with [ __ ] nothing
and he said I was so fascinating he goes
cuz he everyone says like hey look the
fish stinks from the head down but
everybody on those sets were really nice
and I and they work for him over and
over yeah I said why do you guys keep
working from there like wow it's really
hard then you make the movie and then it
comes out and everybody loves it you see
it and so awesome and then you kind of
forget about what it was like and then
he asked you to do it again like but I
need to get paid more and he's like I
can't and then he like pays you out of
pocket but it's why ya can make the
budget small but he pays the people well
so he is like oscar-winning sound mixers
and stuff that are working for him and
so then he like he said well everybody
complains on a movie set right is that
what everybody does everybody just sits
around complaints cuz everybody has so
much time so wardrobe complains about
the sound Department sound Department
complains about how the camera
department keeps complaining about the
sound Department and you know all the PA
is complaining about how long it's
taking for the assistant director to get
the director actually to it he was like
I give them all one thing to complain
about it's me and so everybody complains
to each other about me he goes so what
he was saying was I sort of crucify
myself so that everyone no one is
complaining about each other so they're
all and I thought that was so he's so
funny and he kind of got mad at me about
this but I wish that he would understand
that this is how he described a funny is
cuz he does a lot of work for the
make-a-wish Foundation again he's like
this really good dude and Kate is always
like I don't understand I don't he could
have been a bad onset and I was like
he's it's really really hard Kate and
she's like I don't think so I mean I
we've been to his house warming party
everything he's so sweet to me know my
cabbage I think you're just being
sensitive
like no he grabbed Bobby Lee's face yeah
he made him crying a little fear puh and
and so he had there were make a wish
kids that are on set you know cuz this
you know they love transformers they're
like seeing they're watching it's crazy
they just love it it's it makes it's a
wish I mean that he makes it come true
and I was doing the scene where I throw
the football back and forth with
Wahlberg and now it was a joke slot so I
kept like throwing it and then I did a
couple that kind of missed they just
like I didn't say I'm right and one was
just not funny he's like but we have to
wait and reset to throw the ball and he
just I was it made me laugh so hard he
just was like he came over and he's like
TJ you haven't said one funny thing you
got one more chance to say one just this
is it this your last chance you haven't
been funny this entire scene because you
haven't even made the make-a-wish kids
laugh and I look over and they're all
like we're kind of like he's not being
funny yeah and that is so hilarious to
me but I yelled back here I go you know
what I like about you Michael I like the
confidence do you inspire in your actors
that's my favorite thing yeah the whole
crew just erupted with laughter and he
kind of was like alright alright one
more and then we didn't kill it and it
was great and but he is also very funny
it's like speak very funny these guys
are just so smart that they are funny
and but yeah it was the same deal like I
just I was like I gotta get out of here
and the movie comes out people love it
everybody who's seen it comes at me like
I loved my [ __ ] lyft driver today it
was like two transformers man you died
too early we take a picture I took
visions like this is the first the first
speak person that I've had yeah she's so
excited and you're like that guy loved
transformers I'm so glad I did that film
it was it wasn't worth the suffering
yeah because you do it for the people
not for yourself yeah yeah but people
don't understand when you because I've
also worked with Joe Pitka who was a
Yeller is he yeah and you when you're
actually
there and having to talk with all the
pressure and all the stuff right it just
makes it just puts another element of
like stress you know and it's so not fun
but I guess when you're when you when it
comes out and especially when the years
go by and people come up to you over the
years
and also people buy ticket you know but
when I do stand up on the road oh yeah
oh yeah yeah right so it all helps so
necessary and yeah it's almost like if
you told me you got to go and do the
next Transformers cuz Spielberg even
told me he's like trying to get you into
I want to put you in the next Star Wars
when I put you in the next Transformers
I'm trying to get Michael to put you in
the next Transformers and I was like cuz
we run into each other randomly and his
wife's name is Kate and she's also an
artist that's a weird
it's just weird but and so and I was
like yeah but I I died in it like yeah
but you could come back as a transformer
you know whatever we'll do what I want
to do yeah yeah and he said but I'm
trying to get Michael to switch back and
I was like he's also like mad I mean
right now cuz he heard that make-a-wish
thing or somebody told him about it on I
said it on Doug loves movies and he was
just so upset about it and he wrote me
this email it because I hurt his
feelings he was like I do this thing for
make-a-wish and you're making fun of me
but I wasn't I was trying to explain
he's really fun that's just such a funny
thing to say you're being so unfunny to
make-a-wish kids haven't even laughed
like they all they want to do is laugh
and you're [ __ ] this out that's so
funny to me and they ty said so I don't
think he wants me to be in the next one
but you weren't up making fun of him you
were just telling a story that happened
right yeah so I said so I said I said I
just feel we're going on so he's mad at
me and feel her cuz he goes well you
know he does that with me like every six
months or every year so he'll like yell
at me and he doesn't want to talk to me
for a long time and it's like hell you
Wow he's like yeah yeah he does but he
comes back around he'll come back around
and I said you know what I think I think
he's like a high school kid I think he
has a little bit of a demeanor of
high-school student he's really
sensitive but he's very blustery and he
knows he's really good at something but
he's still he's that he's the best at
something but that he's still kind of
you know he can second-guess himself
he's really sensitive and Spielberg was
like yeah I've never thought of it that
way but I think you're right I think you
might be right about that